wondering what hbo's latest prestige tv
hit in the making is all about
don't worry we've got you covered from
the making of the show to its story and
themes here's all you need to know
before taking a trip into the ambitious
provocative and terrifying world of
lovecraft country
published in 2016 lovecraft country is
the sixth novel by author matt ruff
when ruff worked out the idea he thought
it would make for a great tv show and
wrote the novel as a proof of concept
in other words ruff wrote the book with
the hopes that one day it would get
optioned by hollywood and turned into a
tv series
even though such an idea was an
extraordinary long shot
but within a year ruff's gambit paid off
in may 2017
hbo ordered a series adaptation of
lovecraft country
while a bunch of major industry players
in their production companies signed on
to bring the book to life it still took
more than three long years for the show
to surface
with the first episode of the series
premiering on hbo in august 2020.
in 2017 just a few months after jordan
peele released his thought-provoking
oscar-winning thriller get out deadline
announced the comedian turned
filmmaker's next project
an adaptation of lovecraft country like
get out lovecraft country is a horror
title with plenty to say about race
relations in america
it was peele who discovered the novel
and brought it to hollywood's attention
right out of the gate lovecraft country
boasted some major talent with the track
record to bring such a unique project to
the small screen
hbo ordered a full season of episodes to
be produced by warner brothers
television in association with peel's
monkey paw productions and bad robot
the production company founded by star
wars star trek and lost mastermind j.j
abrams
moreover misha greene the co-creator and
showrunner of the wgn america series
underground signed on as showrunner
green argued that lovecraft country
wouldn't be a viable tv show without the
groundbreaking previous work of peel and
abrams
green said at a television critics
association press tour
i think this would have been incredibly
hard to get on screen if get out hadn't
come out
i think that paved the way for people to
really open up to the idea of seeing
more black people in genre spaces
it's an epic journey that wouldn't have
been possible if we weren't making tv at
the level that started with lost
with a dazzling group of acclaimed
producers and creators to its name along
with its interesting and provocative
source material
lovecraft was able to attract an
impressive all-star cast
betraying one of the lead characters
leticia dandridge is journey smallent
this will be her return to hbo with the
actors previously having enjoyed a
two-year stint on true blood
and we'll also see her reunite with her
underground showrunner misha green
hbo stalwart michael k williams who
played freddie knight on the night of
chalky white on boardwalk empire and
omar little on the wire stars as
montrose freeman atticus's missing
father
acclaimed veteran character actor
courtney b vance who recently won an
emmy for his work as johnny cochran in
american crime story the people vs o.j
simpson had a major role as uncle george
black
and then there's relative newcomer
jonathan magers who looks likely to
become a breakout star in the lead role
of atticus black
one major name who won't be in lovecraft
country however is elizabeth debicki
early on the actor signed up to play the
mysterious and villainous christina
braithwight but had to drop out
her replacement will be abby lee of mad
max fury road fame
lovecraft country is an extremely
original project pulling from a number
of disparate genres and histories
all at once it's a period piece with a
lot to say about systematic racism
a production promising genuine horror
story frights and an exploration of
mid-century science fiction
what's the actual story you ask
lovecraft country is set in the united
states of the 1950s an era absolutely
rife with violent jim crow era racism
the plot follows atticus black a young
black sci-fi enthusiast and korean war
veteran
his uncle george and his childhood
friend leticia as they embark upon a
road trip
in search of atticus's missing father
montrose freeman
the three carefully traveled through the
hostile southern states hoping to avoid
racism
a creepy secret society called the sons
of adam and more than a few monsters
straight out of the works of h.p
lovecraft
these wrathful creatures serve as a
metaphor for the evils of racism but are
also connected
to it what happened to montrose what do
the sons of adam want
he'll have to tune in to find out
betraying atticus freeman in lovecraft
country caps a couple of years of
attention getting high-profile film
roles for jonathan majors
following his work and spike lees to
five bloods and the festival hit the
last black man in san francisco
he prepared extensively for his role in
lovecraft country telling the new york
times
the first thing i do when i start a role
is i look to see where we're similar i
played sports my entire life that speaks
to the physicality of atticus
prepping the imagination of the
character one victimized by racism and
violence was more difficult
major said i had to go to places of
remembering when i was beaten up so bad
in school that i retaliated and ran to
my apartment building
and grabbed a knife and was chasing the
bully down the street like the fear i
had pulsing through my body
veteran actor journey smallit will play
one of lovecraft country's primary roles
leticia lewis atticus freeman's
traveling partner and childhood friend
with whom things have grown complicated
in adulthood
smallits is best known for her roles as
michelle's best friend denise on full
house
black canary and birds of prey and
rosalie in underground
the wgn america series about the
underground railroad co-created by
lovecraft country creator and showrunner
misha green
but just because the two had worked
together before doesn't mean they always
got along
or that the process of casting smallhead
on the show was easy
the actress told the hollywood reporter
we did the pilot and i hated her
we proceeded to be the worst of enemies
for the first two months of shooting
green confirmed that assessment to
acknowledging tough times on the
underground set between the two
she said their animosity toward each
other became an on-set inside joke
but once they worked out a communication
style that worked for both of them
they ended up becoming friends or at
least not outright enemies since
lovecraft country sees them working
together again
when she signed on to make lovecraft
country green knew that smallit was the
right actor to play leticia but she
resisted the instinct to caster at first
green told the hollywood reporter i just
didn't want to be one of those people
who only works with actors they've
worked with before
smallit was determined to get the part
that she was a huge fan of matt ruff's
source novel of the same name and
tracked the show's development progress
through it all she didn't understand why
it took green a long five months to
offer her the role
in her hollywood reporter interview
smallit recounted her paranoia at the
lack of contact
asking rhetorically does she not think i
can stretch and do a different character
i mean i was freaking out literally
losing sleep for months
up until a few years ago the negro
motorist green book was a little-known
but fascinating relic of american and
segregationist history
between 1936 and 1966 an
african-american postal worker named
victor greene published
annual directories advising
african-american travelers as to which
hotels restaurants nightclubs bars
saloons and gas stations would accept
their business
green's books distributed under a
variety of different names covered
locales
all over the world but which were
particularly valuable in the south where
businesses openly segregated or refused
african-american patrons
until the civil rights act of 1964 made
such practices illegal
all of these concepts were brought to
mass attention by the movie green book
the 2018 academy award winner for best
picture about a white man who drives an
african-american concert pianist through
the segregated 60s south
hbo's lovecraft country also explores
the importance of the green book but in
a much more personal and provocative way
part of atticus black's traveling group
is his uncle george black played by
courtney b
vance for the purposes of this show he
is the highly informed author of the
safe negro travel guide
an obviously fictionalized version of
the negro motorist green book
whether his books in the tv show have
anything to say about what travelers
should do against any ancient unknowable
godlike monsters they may encounter
that remains to be seen the lovecraft in
lovecraft country refers to h.p
lovecraft a pioneer in science fiction
and horror literature who laid out a lot
of the genre standards and tropes which
are still used today
lovecraft also helped popularize the
notion of a unified fictional world in
which to set multiple otherwise not
explicitly connected works
not unlike the marvel cinematic universe
or harry potter's wizarding world
lovecraft set many of his stories in
fake towns within massachusetts real
essex county
some lovecraft scholars refer to the
area as the miss catanic region
after a fictional river and university
found in those fictional works
while the lovecraftian game call of
cthulhu spread the phrase lovecraft
country
however the term lovecraft country as
the title of a show about racial issues
is also a subtle criticism of that
author's worldview
h.p lovecraft had some disturbing
opinions on race so in other words
lovecraft
country is a metaphor for racist stuff
for example the real-life lovecraft
espoused anti-semitic conspiracy
theories sympathized with hitler and
justified anti-black violence in the
south
and the people behind the book and show
were very aware of this
lovecraft country and its hbo adaptation
grapple with lovecraft's legacy
the same way many readers of his work do
today yes he was an important author and
indelible in the development of genre
fiction but he wasn't the most
progressive individual
while lovecraft country is set in the
past albeit an alternate version of the
past in which literal monsters are a
legitimate threat to the protagonist
its themes still resonate today
lovecraft country is primarily about
black characters traveling through a
country where
sundown towns exist exclusionary places
where black people can be attacked with
no recourse if they're in public at
night
it's all packaged in a show that's
hitting hbo mere weeks after massive
nationwide protests called for an
end to police brutality systematic
racism and a reinvigoration of the black
lives matter movement
during a lovecraft country panel for
comic con at home 2020
star jonathan majors read a scene in
which his character is pulled over by a
white police officer during his travels
and he could relate to the fear and
uncertainty out of his feels
majors told variety literally on top of
my script for that scene i wrote the
worst day in texas
where i grew up this is the type of
thing my mama would pray over me when i
would travel
pray that wouldn't happen it is
something that is
ancient you know that systematic racism
that that bullying his co-star on the
show courtney b vance all but labeled
lovecraft country vital viewing
saying during the panel watch lovecraft
country because it's so different and so
engaging
especially in this time period we're
living in now you know you thought you
had something going on with with game of
thrones but
watch out check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and tv
shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one